[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ceux qui s'y sont interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
c'est le sentiment que vous avez eue
vous aussi ce besoin d'autonomie
oui complètement a besoin d'autonomie
besoin de retourner à des choses plus
essentielles en fait est vraiment de
sentir qu'on n'est pas forcément un
poids pour la planète
il ya une idée derrière il ya une
philosophie aussi qu'on a vu la serre
les plantes qui poussent le fait de
vivre avec les plantes comme ça vraiment
commune comme une machine un organisme
pour fait partie de cet organisme
on a eu vraiment l'impression de se
construire en même temps qu'on vous
construisez cette maison en faisant
toutes ces rencontres mais je pense que
ces gens de projets qui se fait pas tout
seul dans son coin on est dans un truc
vraiment de coopération de partage de
partage
[Musique]
bienvenue dans pôle it mag l'émission
politique d arte france comme tous les
week-ends on débat avec nos
contributeurs des grands sujets de
l'actualité politique de la semaine
aujourd'hui nous sommes avec florian
philippot conseiller régional du grand
est et président des patriotes et face à
vous jean paul huchon président
honoraire du conseil régional d'île de
france
invité sur ce plateau également olivier
pardo avocat d'eric zemmour du cabinet
opus merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur rt france et c'est à la
une cette semaine regarder la très
controversée loi avia adopté en seconde
lecture par les députés cette semaine
une loi censée lutter contre la haine
sur internet qui suscite de nombreuses
oppositions associations partis
politiques et institutions dénoncent un
texte contreproductif qui pourrait
inciter les plateformes numériques à la
censure
la haine sur internet et dans les médias
dans l'actualité cette semaine avec le
procès d'eric zemmour mercredi qui a été
renvoyée au 13 mai prochain
je considère ici que ce dispositif
risque d'aller vers une prime à la
censure clairement les priver les
plateformes privilégiant la censure
faciles rapides plutôt que des sanctions
plus lourdes
mais la toile de fond organise également
de votre dispositif l'effacement du juge
judiciaire
pourtant garante des libertés au profit
du csa autorité administrative dont
l'indépendance du pouvoir en place n'est
franchement pas garanti nous pensons que
ce texte est déséquilibré dans la mesure
où il va confier à des sociétés
multinationales privées le pouvoir et la
privatisation d'une censure de contenus
qu'ils détermineraient eux mêmes comme
licite ou illicite et au moment où on
nous exhorte chaque jour pratiquement va
trouver les moyens de réguler ces gars
femmes on va leur demander de réguler ce
qui nous est le plus cher qui flirtait
d'expression allait lutter contre la
haine partout sur internet sur le
terrain c'est ce qu'a rappelé cedrico le
secrétaire d'état au numérique également
à l'assemblée nationale cette semaine
florian philippot le fait de légiférer
pour contrer la haine sur sur les
réseaux sociaux dans un premier temps
sns la bonne méthode ce nom vous déjà le
problème de base c'est qu'est ce qu'on
appelle la n va bien qu'on a déjà un
premier problème c'est qu'on va être sur
une définition extrêmement flou et donc
dans l'arbitraire de la même manière
dans la loi apparaît la notion de
dignité humaine je crois qu'on est tous
pour la dignité humaine mais ça amène
également à des choses assez flou le
deuxième problème c'est qu'effectivement
la loi et d'ailleurs vous intéresse vous
interrogez député habia et ceux qui ceux
qui sont à l'origine de ce texte pour le
défendre ils vous disent clairement
explicitement il faut aller vite il faut
contourner jeu reprend les mots il faut
contourner le juge
bon alors contourné le juge judiciaire
se dire qu'on tournait celui qui
normalement dans notre équilibre
institutionnel et gardien des libertés
individuelles et publiques et donnait
effectivement ça a été dit à l'instant
le pouvoir aux plateformes privées aux
gars femmes aux réseaux sociaux qui vont
d'ailleurs agir très vite par précaution
parce que la loi prévoit qu'ils sont
dépasse les 24 heures il ya une très
forte amende
donc en quelque sorte le doute trop
ultra l'accusation par la défense est
dans le doute on supprimera et on
supprimera de manière automatique par un
algorithme parce que ça sera impossible
de mettre en place des systèmes avec des
gens derrière leur ordinateur en
permanence pour vérifier ce qu'ils
écrivent aussi donc on va tomber en
réalité dans une espèce de
d'automatismes qui sera contraire à la
liberté d'expression sur des critères
complètement flou et arbitraire ou le
juge ne sera plus là alors le problème
de fond c'est quoi c'est qu'aujourd'hui
avec les réseaux sociaux la technologie
évidemment il ya beaucoup plus de prise
de parole qu'avant tout simplement donc
il peut y avoir beaucoup plus de propos
problématique dans le problématique des
choses clairement illégaux illégal mais
aussi des choses qui seront jugés
haineuse par certains ou acceptable par
d'autres et là on est dans le flou mais
simplement parce que souvent signalés
par ces mêmes personnes
certes auparavant n'y avait pas ces
réseaux sociaux il n'y avait pas donc
évidemment il y avait moins de capacités
y avait moins de possibilités
d'expression
ceci dit soit on conserve les principes
et c'est bien à la justice a posteriori
de décider de ce qui est légal ou pas et
de garde conserver de préserver nos
libertés et pour cela il faut donc
renforcer les moyens de la justice voit
pas d'autres solutions soit on considère
comme le fait cette loi via que nos
principes doivent être bafouée et on
donne un pouvoir a priori à des acteurs
privés transnationaux qui vont décider
pour nous et à notre place de notre
liberté d'expression
moi je trouve que c'est extrêmement
dangereux olivier pardo effectivement
tout internaute pourra signaler les
contenus visés qui devront être je cite
manifestement entre guillemets illicites
qu'est ce que ça veut dire tout un terme
au delà pouvoir s'ériger en juge
ça veut dire qu'on est passé d'une loi
sur la liberté d'expression qui était
loi d'avocats à une loi de procureurs et
une loi de procureurs au pluriel c'est à
dire que vous avez aujourd'hui toute une
série de procureur vous avez le csa
l'état procureur procureurs et juges ce
qui déjà un véritable problème
vous avez les associations qui s'érige
en procureur et aujourd'hui vous allez
avoir les internautes eux mêmes qui vont
être en procureur avec une position des
entreprises qui vont être leurs propres
juges contournant ainsi le judiciaire
c'est à dire les avocats toutes les
garanties c'est ça qui est dangereux
c'est celle amalgame c'est la
superposition qui devient extrêmement
période l'intention est bonne
l'udc est contrôlé le décor mais
regardez est ce qu'à un moment donné
avec toutes ces lois avec tous ces
empilements est-ce que la haine a
diminué moi j'ai plutôt le sentiment que
l'on a fait de ces lois des instruments
politiques et que les vrais racistes les
vrais homophobe des vrais antisémites et
pullulent
aujourd'hui ils sont beaucoup plus
puissants et vous verrez qu'ils seront
encore plus puissants parce qu'ils vont
contourner des éléments c'est là un
petit peu une législation en perdition
est ce que c'est à dire que de
s'exprimer mais il existe néanmoins ceux
qui sont vraiment des racistes et
antisémites et homophobes y en a ça
serait fou que de nier d'un verre s'ils
sont de plus en plus fort et de plus en
plus nombreux et c'est généralement pas
eux que l'on poursuit
c'est cela qui pose problème ce que l'on
poursuit ce sont des gens qui ont une
idéologie qu n'est pas une idéologie
mainstream mais c'est sûr non pas les
antisémites des racistes et des
homophobes agents pollution est ce qu'il
faut légiférer pour éviter la haine sur
internet selon vous côté depuis quelques
émissions avec gucci différents
contributeurs
on constate le développement du violence
verbale de
un extra et donc ça préoccupe tout le
monde et tout le monde a envie d'agir
mais le problème que mes interlocuteurs
l'ont dit tout à l'heure il va y avoir
de plus en plus de contenu de ce type
est loin maintenant obliger à retirer le
contenu sont sous 24 heures mais s'il ya
des faits retoquer au sénat mais quand
même revenu à l'assemblée nationale on
voit bien ce qui va se passer c'est à
dire que les gaffes avons tout arrêter
voilà et alors ça veut dire que il
pourra continuer à voir des diatribes
etc mais qui qui seront pas punissable
donc ce qui risque de se passer c'est
une espèce de de vide sidéral dans
lequel tombent ont toutes ces
proclamations de haine à travers la
diffusion
l'image où nous vous de contenu mais
faites moi je ne suis pas sûr c'est chez
moi je suis inquiet de inquiet du fait
qu'on puisse développer une censure
totale c'est à peu près tout je veux
dire c'est comme ça qui est en cause
c'est un tribunal de la bien-pensance
aujourd'hui c'est charles on en est la
même et ça l'a bien pensants c'est ce
tribunal de dés des bisounours un voile
assez d'emmerdés
mais je crois honnêtement on est dans
une société qui devient de plus en plus
irrespirable et c'est un problème pour
l'intelligence pour la création basque
une société où on ne peut plus rien dire
on a peur je vous assure il y compris
maintenant dans les hémicycles
parfois vous avez des élus au lieu de
débattre il vous envoie une menace comme
ça dans l'hémicycle souvent verbales ya
pas de conséquences mais parfois ils le
font quand même d'aller porter plainte
parce que alors que ce que vous avez dit
n'est ni dans l'insigne à des formations
mixtes amm et simplement le propos ne
leur convient pas idéologiquement et
donc il mais ils ont pris ce réflexe ce
réflexe on le retrouve partout on a
parlé
peut-être qu'on en parlera à mettre
cette jeune milla savez la lycéenne la
kia alors elle a dit de manière vulgaire
on est d'accord 1 elle a critiqué
fortement une religion l'islam bon pour
les raisons qui lui appartiennent et son
expérience personnelle elle l'a fait
hier la saison telle virulence
effectivement une certaine vulgarité
certaine virulence aux facéties libre la
vulgarité pas encore totalement illégal
et elle a en tout cas critiqué la
religion et la mère qui l'avait fait
avant elle pour allart il a été mêlé
mais non il est innocenté c'était que la
seconde une réactualisation la la relaxe
et va j'espère qu'on peut critiquer
toutes les religions et qui a pas de
rétablissement du délit de blasphème
pour l'instant en france mais il se
trouve que l a été on le sait menacé de
mort à des milliers de milliers de fois
ces réseaux sociaux son adresse a été
donnée à la du est déscolarisé d'urgence
et c'est quand même grave estime le
procureur qu'est ce qu'il a fait et a
lancé une enquête contre les les menaces
de mort très bien heureusement mais il a
en même temps un peu dans le même temps
dans le mac rognan il a lancé il a lancé
une enquête contre elle pour incitation
à la haine raciale
donc je ne savais pas d'abord que
l'islam était une race et ensuite je ne
vois pas ce que l'incitation à la haine
raciale vient faire là dedans mais il
l'a fait quand même
alors je pense j'espère qu'elle sera
relaxé
mais c'est quand même une espèce ça sera
perçu comme un gage donné là au vrai
mais je vous rejoins totalement 16 ans
un la queue saison mais est ce qu'elle
est responsable le procureur lui en
décidant de cette incitation à la haine
raciale cette enquête pour incitation et
mal il donne des gages à ceux qui sont
les vrais violent les vrais dingues les
vrais l'est ce qui menace de mort ceux
qui ont probablement à côté des propos
souvent antisémite ou homophobes ou
racistes ou je ne sais quoi et on se
sente en quelque sorte légitimé par cela
donc si vous voulez on est dans une
société où effectivement il ya des
propos qui pullulent dans certains
quartiers on le sait ou sur les réseaux
et qui sont franchement illégaux
inadmissible mais qui sont rarement
poursuivis et vous avez à côté cela un
débat démocratique un débat intellectuel
dirais même plus que dans le champ
politique un débat intellectuel qui est
corseté de toute part parce qu'on n'ose
même plus parler parce qu'on a peur
d'être le lendemain devant le tribunal
et d'être condamné à 20 ans de prison
prison avec sursis une lisibilité ou je
ne sais quoi est ce que c'est un
irrespirable et c'est très français et
c'est très français ce que ça se fait
avec la complicité des médias jean paul
huchon le fait de ne plus inviter
certains polémiste on va parler
évidemment du cas d'eric zemmour dans
quelques instants
mais est ce qui nous touche censure
aussi de la part de certains médias
justement pour ne pas ne pas trop
provoquer ne pas tomber dans l'excès est
resté dans la bien pensante médiatique
oui c'est ça mais je veux dire ça
conduit à une télévision des médias une
information qui donne de plus en plus
dans l'eau tiède dans l'eau tiède à
travers des provocations un peu minable
mais pas vraiment des débats où on peut
vraiment dire ce qu'on a mais absolument
il d'ailleurs on le fait ici on le fait
ailleurs
donc moi je crois que la technologie et
la multiplication des messages
avec les internautes il y à l'entente
qu'il ya une guerre que commencer avec
la liberté d'expression et on est en
train de la perdre
c'est à dire que de plus en plus on va
aller vers les interdictions de toutes
natures et après tout je veux dire moi
j'aurais tendance à dire qu'il vaudrait
mieux laisser
les gens parler et puis bon la justice
bon la justice il faudrait qu'elle soit
présente il faudrait ofii et des juges
formés pour ça qui est des îles et des
gens presque c'est finalement tout
simplement sur internet quand il ya un
propos qui sont excessifs
il y as forcément une organisation
derrière est-ce que ça compense pas non
parce que sur internet est devenu en
grande partie une zone de non droit
parce que c'est très difficile à
poursuivre il ya toute une série de
d'empêchement juridique et judiciaire
et du coup le juge est désemparé à cela
il est un peu comme l'alcool et qui
cherche ses clefs sous le lampadaire
parce qu'il ya de la lumière alors qu'il
sait très bien que les a perdus ailleurs
et que au fond on vient là où c'est
facile ou c'est pas difficile d'aller
poursuivre eric zemmour et j'ai d'autres
clients qui sont dans le même cas parce
qu'ils sont dans la lumière
alors qu'on en fait on en fait même pas
des exemples parce qu'ils sont pas dans
ce registre là ils sont dans un autre
registre est un registre politique
intellectuel de combat idéologique alors
que l'on sait c'est ça qui me qui me
choque profondément
alors que l'on sait qu'il ya des
véritables campagnes haineuses qui sont
mises en place il ya des véritables
réseaux sur l'antisémitisme qui est
extrêmement fort dans notre pays
beaucoup plus fort qu'il ne l'était il
ya dix quinze ans est bien là il ya une
sorte de deux politiques de déclaration
magnifique fort bien mais ya pas
tellement une politique d'action et que
à la vérité quand on veut poursuivre ces
cas flagrant on finit par poursuivre
autre chose et c'est cela qui est
dangereux c'est parce que on perd le
sens de ce qu'est le véritable débat
pour la liberté d'expression c'est à
dire la liberté d'expression est un
principe avec quelques limites
quelques limites qui est dont les objets
un juridiques existent déjà et dans les
objets juridiques existent déjà et quand
vous prenez par exemple à payer comme
les états unis
vous avez une vous avez un principe le
prince et miro 1 de la constitution qui
est la liberté d'expression il n'empêche
qu'il ya une régulation juridique et
judiciaire qui est extrêmement forte
alors qu'en france vous avez une
régulation administrative une régulation
judiciaire et maintenant je ris nul
assure économique parce que tout cela va
coûter très cher et que suivre et
assumer toute une série de procédures
scouts à un coût extrêmement lourds qui
à un moment donné vont faire que
certains vont se dire si je dois pas la
peine bien sûr alors eric zemmour
devaient être jugés mercredi après ses
propos tenus le 28 septembre dernier
lors de la convention de la droite un
discours diffusé en intégralité sur la
chaîne lci
le procès a donc été renvoyée au 13 mai
prochain il doit répondre eric zemmour
des chefs d'injures publiques à
caractère racial et de provocation
publique à la haine raciale pour ses
mots souvenez-vous en france comme dans
toute l'europe
tous nos problèmes sont aggravées je ne
dis pas créer mais aggravées par
l'immigration et tous nos problèmes
aggravés par l'immigration sont aggravés
par l'islam ils se comportent en
colonisateur
dans la rue les femmes voilées les
hommes en djellaba sont une propagande
par le fait une islamisation de la rue
alors je vous demandais tout à l'heure
un olivier pardo est ce que eric zemmour
doit faire figure d'exemple justement
pour tous ceux qui le poursuivent
aujourd'hui quelque est ce que vous avez
à dire pour sa défense alors beaucoup de
choses mais je vais essayer d'être
d'être assez bref
d'abord vous venez de le voir et rivaux
il savait pas qu'il était filmé quand on
dit injures publiques il faut qu'il y
ait une publicité la convention était
privée fallait rentrer y avait débat
agité sur invitation la station
habitations bon ça rend déjà un premier
problème
deuxième problème la citation lui
procure la république fait deux pages
extrêmement longues avec des propos
extrêmement et vous avez un mal fou à
savoir exactement les mots qui lui sont
reprochés vous savez quand vous faites
une citation en diffamation vous devez
marquer surligner
les propos mais quelques lignes qui sont
retenus c'est à dire quand vous dites
bonjour monsieur e
bienvenue donc c'est ok que je sais que
c'est diffamatoire
ensuite et je n'aurais terminée il ya un
principe simple soit c'est de l'injure
sûr c'est de la diffamation procureur a
choisi de poursuivre les mêmes propos
pour injure et diffamation raciale et
j'ajoute un point c'est la rapidité
toute personne publique soit monsieur
philippe aux messieurs huchon dans sa
vie publique a forcément eu des procès
en diffamation
ça met des mois j'avais ddd voire des
années les journalistes d'empalot par la
sas est tenue je crois à l'automne c'est
ça qui a saisi le procureur oui ça s'est
tenue à l'automne et on s'est retrouvé
en janvier pour une audience
j'étais grévistes dans le cadre de la
grève des avocats donc le tribunal a
repoussé mais c'était quand même très
rapide
est ce que eric zemmour et l'antisémite
le raciste et homophobe
si violent qu'il faut le poursuivre tous
les jours ça n'a pas de sens alors
certains disant il faut poursuivre non
pas eric zemmour mais aussi la lhn
puisque ça a été diffusé sur une chaîne
publique ne l'aurait fait sans diffusion
je n'aurais pas forcément été poursuivis
oublier racheter quelque chose jean paul
huchon
oui les responsabilités du diffuseur
comme diffuseur il prend ses risques
quand il autorise des muscles se dit
tout le monde a la mérite et d'ailleurs
on n'a pas diffusé
je vous avais vu sa tête vous avez vous
connaissez les xénons autonome des mots
c'est pas les riques zemmour que l'on
connaît la télévision il est penché sur
son texte il dit un témoin on sent bien
qui n'est pas dans une logique qui est
une logique pour que ça soit diffusé des
grades lors qu'il est filmé quand même
parce que mais il est avant non mais ne
savait pas avant de commencer savait pas
quand tu prépares athex qui vit que la
lettre est allé dans la préparation de
son texte mais non moi je viens de
revoir les propos honnêtement je suis
pas agriculteur qui ont fait 1 qui ont
fait les deux qui que le 10 auteur de
guides mais si vous attaquez le lion par
les musulmans dans leur ensemble des
immigrés non les immigrés c'est qu'ils
amassent des italiens c'est des amours
cdc qui vous avez vous avez vous avez
des noms mais vous avez en france des
associations prétendument contre
l'islamophobie qui sont spécialistes
vous leur dites devant la voulais
qu'elles sont en face vous leur dites
les islamistes sont des gens
insupportable qu'il faut et même
criminels qu'il faut combattre
ils entendent elles veulent entendre les
musulmans donc moi je les connaissais un
marqueur ses fonctions elle en réalité
qui font les amalgames
alors que vous avez fait exprès
d'employer le bon mot bon donc si vous
voulez le fait qu'on veuille entendre
quand ils parlent les colonisateurs
forcément qui parlent tous les musulmans
ça c'est parce qu'il dit non il choisit
pas que j'aurais fait mieux à ce
discours on parle chacun comme on parle
on a chacun ses combats on a chacun suit
pas forcément tout le temps d'accord
avec eric zemmour ya d'autres parties où
je suis tout jeune bon d'accord bonta
gravé par l'immigration l'école suzanne
aussi comme discours dans la vie
politique mais qu'il dise oui à des
phénomènes aggravée par les migrations
qui est aggravée par l'islamisation je
ne sais quoi mais j'espère qu'on a
encore le droit d'y recenser mais aussi
par l'islam s'étaient classés alors on
est loin de dire ça je veux dire on a le
droit de juger une religion on a le
droit de juger l'impact politique d'une
religion n'importe quelle religion de
moi je suis honnêtement choquer pour
l'intelligence de notre débat
démocratique et même l'ouverture d'une
enquête sur ça mais ça c'est vais
évidemment fait pour des raisons
politiques parce que moi je me suis un
très bien du tollé qui a eu lieu juste
après la diffusion de cette affaire est
que ce soit diffusé pour moi sur lci ou
pas je comprends l'argument juridique
mais je ne vois aucun problème à la
diffusion en direct de tout cela 7 il ya
eu un tollé politique avec intervention
se croit de ministre
deux députés de la majorité et c était
soit disant extrêmement choqué parce
qu'ils avaient entendu est effectivement
juste après la justice a laissé sa
justice et à dégainer donc on est
évidemment avec la rapidité que vous
soulignez et m et vous avez raison parce
qu'effectivement on connaît ses affaires
ses rangs beaucoup plus longs avec la
rapidité que vous soulignez ce qui
prouve qu'on est dans un contexte très
politique c'est choquant qu'on s'ils
voulaient qu'on passe son temps en
france devant les tribunaux pour ce
genre de choses dont feraient mieux de
réfléchir au fond de ce qu'il dit
d'accord pas d'accord on débat en
argumente on peut temporiser on veut
c'est bien c'est comme ça qu'on fera
progresser des idées et comprendra deux
bonnes décisions j'espère pour le pays
mais c'est ça qu'on devrait faire en
france plutôt que de passer notre temps
à discuter une discutailler d'un mot
devant des tribunes on a reproché
justement à la chaîne lci de ne pas
mettre suffisamment en exergue ses
propos de ne pas les commenter après
coup écoutez ce que ce que dit l'avocat
de la maison des pôles qui est à
l'origine de cette plainte aussi contre
eric zemmour la maison les fans que nous
disons c'est que ces propos sont
récurrents reviennent systématiquement
mal sphère publique
il ya principalement un responsable
aujourd'hui c'est la diffusion de ses
coûts et lci et est la chaîne qui a
diffusé de a à z
in extenso sans qu sans coupure sans
interprétation journalistique permettant
de décoder le discours de haine qui
était pratiqué par eric zemmour et donc
nous avons fait citer lci pour quel
seuil et rendent des comptes et paul est
très intéressant la maison des potes
moi j'ai découvert cette association et
dieu sait que je fais du droit de la
presse depuis des années très récemment
c'est à dire que tous les jours c'est
pourtant une vieille histoire
oui j'ai l'histoire de ce laxisme des
distances de la soie et strass il est
tout à coup ils viennent et qu'est-ce
qui viennent dire c'est intéressant ce
que dit karsenti il dit moi ce qui me
choque c'est la diffusion en réalité ce
qui choque c'est qu'eric zemmour
s'exprime c'est son expression
ce qui est insupportable pour bout
ou c'est qu'il ait du succès quand le
veuille ou non et on peut partager ne
pas partager
moi je suis son avocat donc je me
prononce pas sur ce qu'il dit je défends
on peut partager ou pas partagé mais
c'est devenu un intellectuel majeur du
débat culturel et intellectuel en france
c'est comme ça c'est ainsi que ça plaise
ou pas c'est comme cela et tout à coup
on voudrait que celui ci n'est plus de
possibilités parce que chaque fois on
demande qu'il soit interdit d'exercice
ont été condamnés dans une première
affaire en septembre 2016 exactement sur
france 5 pour des propos condamnés à
3000 euros damende voilà il a été
condamné après lille revient il
reviendra alors vous parliez des médias
qui le dit fils mal hors cessions
d'audience alors d'abord d'abord une
question de l'eau dure je vois il a
perdu quand même rtl qui était un grand
diffuseur à cause de cela sur une
affaire qui était le 'corriere della
serra où on lui avait reproché à vous
qui l'avez jamais prononcé sur la
déportation et on a gagné devant la cour
de cassation sur des affaires dit
procédure on en a gagné 9,8 pardon il y
en a une on a perdu parce qu'il n'a pas
voulu faire appel et la deuxième est
pendant devant la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme
donc vous voyez c'est pas aussi simple
que cela
mais il ya une volonté affichée de le
faire taire parce que il porte un
discours qui est un discours qui va pied
majeur dans la société et faire taire ce
discours c'est une folie
c'est une folie parce que ça voudra dire
que à ce moment là il vous imaginez
l'argent le le les moyens qui sont mis
en place
quand on est reçu par les services de
police il ya trois policiers des
procureurs
il ya des audiences qui dure toute une
journée longue et une après midi
il ya des audiences qui dure deux jours
deux jours devant une justice qui est
elle même à des problèmes de moyens
est-ce qu'il ya pas plus graves sk par
quelque chose de plus important pour la
justice que de passer deux jours a jugé
eric zemmour pour savoir si ce qu'il a
dit
concerne tous les musulmans une partie
des musulmans l'islam l'islamisme et c
c'est quelque chose qui est aberrant et
qui est un dévoiement de la loi la loi
elle est fait pour condamner des délits
c'est à dire l'antisémitisme le racisme
l'homophobie et c'est pas pour mettre
dans les prétoires un débat intellectuel
rester avec nous on continue ce débat
bien sûr sur la propagation de la haine
sur internet dans les médias et dans la
rue pourquoi tant de haine dans les
propos et aussi dans les réactions qu'il
suscite
faut-il des lois pour en finir on en
parle dans quelques minutes à tout de
suite
[Musique]
la crise de 2008 arrive et à ce moment
là on s'aperçoit que les choses ont été
mal faites
on n'avait aucunement prévu des
scénarios de crise de défaut de paiement
tant qu'on maintient la grèce avec les
mêmes conditions qui ont provoqué cette
crise vous aurez le même système
il serait plus cohérent qu'elle reprenne
son existence en main monnaie comprise
mais je reprendre sa monnaie ne résout
pas tous les toutous les problèmes bien
sûr qu'il faut changer les hommes qui
dirigent parce que sinon vous ne
résoudrait rien en sortant de l'euro on
veut en fait forcé la marche du
transformation d'un pays donc
effectivement peut-être que certains
grecs ont envie de voir cette marche de
transformation du phoning sans aucun
doute une grande partie n'ont pas envie
des sacs transformation son entrée dans
l'euro est en grande partie responsable
de ce qui lui arrivait
[Musique]
la france a été la destination
principale des peintres russes dans la
seconde moitié du xviie siècle
[Musique]
repin épauler nord c'est un ton les
connais pas par leur nom mais on les
connaît par les tableaux qu'ils ont fait
nous vivions pour peu de son est très
joyeusement mais nous y travaillons
aussi très sérieusement écrit bogoliubov
une école c'est unique de mire même
temps la lumière est très proche de
celle de la russie
chez nous la rivière c'est la volga ici
c'est la mer et saint louis 6 argent tu
es si belle et romantique
le vent est aussi intense et puissant
[Musique]
c'est quoi pour vous fine république
éthique
écoutez c'est une république qui se
préoccupent de lutter contre la
corruption et contre la fraude fiscale
qui a conscience que c'est un enjeu
considérable
le coût de la corruption et est évalué à
pour la france chaque année à 120
milliards le coût de la fraude fiscale
entre 80 et 100 milliards chaque année
évidemment cet argent pourrait être
beaucoup mieux employé quand il affirme
claude fillion la classe politique
rappelez-vous étaient sidérés ne
comprenait pas le problème parce qu'il
faisait tout ça depuis des années chaque
année on nous avons nous découvrons des
pratiques des combines et c c'est sans
fin je pense que la population les
citoyens ne réclame pas suffisamment
cette moralisation du citoyen à une doit
reprendre sa place
et toi sanctionner les élus indélicats
et doit promouvoir au contraire ceux qui
proposent des mesures visant à éviter
les abus
[Musique]
pôle it mag la suite avec nos
contributeurs florian philippot jean
paul huchon est notre invité olivier
pardo avocat d'eric zemmour du cabinet
caucus on continue de parler de la
propagation de la haine sur internet
avec l'adoption en seconde lecture cette
semaine de la loi avia avec des pouvoirs
étendus notamment pour le csa le conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel jean paul
huchon est ce que c'est devenu un outil
politique quand on voit que le csa on en
a parlé
saisie maintenant les tribunaux quand il
ya des débordements sûr sûr sûr sûr les
médias et bientôt sur internet
je crois que c'est ça on peut pas dire
qu'il ya un track-record impeccable mais
parle par l'état mais je fais bien mais
la plupart du temps il a quand même pris
des décisions à la fois sur ce type de
questions mais officiant l'equilibre des
programmes des chaînes et c'est très
contestable et il a été dirigé de
manière assez assez centré à la demande
du pouvoir donc moi je ne fais aucune
confiance quand tu te laisses ta main
sur quelque peu parce que il chaque fois
qu'on a à nommer des gens ou qu'on a dû
autoriser tel ou tel type d'émission ils
se sont
un petit peu couvert de ridicule c'est
c'est une institution qui a fonctionné
pendant un certain temps et depuis il
rêve depuis que je ramais qu'à sa tête
et les autres autour de lui c'est pas
c'est pas brillant c'est bien plus
politique vous pensez le c'est une
affaire comme ça ne peut se juger que
devant la justice de ses ça est une
source de bonnes idées
les autorités administratives entre
guillemets indépendant ça ne fonctionne
j'utilise à jouer ce rôle
d'autant qu'il ya une mise en garde à en
parler de d'eric zemmour de ces propos
tenus sur lci mise en garde pour lci
une mise en demeure pour la chaîne c
news donc une sanction beaucoup plus
lourde
oui et vous verrez que il ya une
politique du csa vis-à-vis des chaînes
de monsieur bolloré qui était une
politique plus redoutable parce que vous
verrez que ces 8 a également fait
l'objet de sanctions extrêmement lourd
de remise en cause d'ailleurs devant le
conseil d'état pour quelles raisons
selon vous parce que à un moment donné
il y a des positions qui sont des
positions différentes
et comme le disait excellemment jean
paul huchon une autorité administrative
indépendante
c'est le mot indépendante qui est en
question déjà autorité administrative
c'est un oxymore soit vous êtes
administratif saoud est indépendant
l'indépendance c'est la justice celle là
on peut considérer que les juges du
siège
il faut la considérer comme cela alors
s'il ya en tous les cas c'est une vertu
vers laquelle on va et on se sauve
j'étais magistrat à l'origine donc je le
sais on se sent habité par cette
indépendance
je suis pas sûr avec tout le respect que
je dois à des énarques qui sont en face
d'eux et narciso surprise en que la
culture de l'administration soit
forcément le la culture de
l'indépendance il me semble qu'elle ait
plus de la culture de l'autorité
l'autorité de l'état l'autorité
démocratique l'autorité républicaine
mais l'autorité après on peut évoluer
dans une vie
et changer en tous les cas la formation
est plutôt tournée vers cela je ne crois
pas dire pour tous les ans nous vous
êtes aidez des hommes politiques
aujourd'hui donc ça n'a rien à voir non
mais sur le banc
non mais c'est vrai c'est ça c'est une
autorité administrative indépendante on
n'a jamais trop bien su capter le stade
succès autoritaire ministre hâtive
indépendante
moi j'ai le sentiment effectivement qui
serait très indépendant mais d'ailleurs
sur les sur les signalements parce que
souvent on entend le sait ça nous a fait
part depuis 832 signalement sur tel ou
tel propos ou telle émission telle ou
telle chaîne là on a eu 100 ans 44
signalement problème c'est que tout cela
est instrumentalisé circuit aujourd'hui
les réseaux sociaux vous pouvez créer
des campagnes de signalement donc en
réalité
bon bah pour des raisons associations
qui sont punir mais bien sûr il ya les
associations qui savent très bien faire
ça envoie un message tout y est ou fait
copier coller à lormes en bois ou sur
leurs réseaux et puis vous avez lincou
500 signalements alors on sait bien
qu'il ya quelque chose d'important donc
il faut que le csa agissent alors c'est
très artificielle tout ça ces problèmes
là où le csa pourrait avoir devrait
avoir son utilité c'est sûr par exemple
l'équilibré des temps de parole des
opinions la diversité des opinions des
partis politiques etc
à l'antenne oui enfin voilà pour les
enfants enfin voilà ce genre de chouy
voilà des gens sur les sur la qualité
des programmes etc où la diversité des
opinions et je trouve que là il a un peu
en retrait bon sur la diversité des
opinions sur les chaînes honnêtement on
n'y est pas en france on ne sait quand
il ya quand même alors on peut le saisir
on nous ont fait tant entend enfin
d'autres le font c'est sain c'est avec
des résultats hasardeux mais sur la
qualité des programmes je ne penserai
pas
parce que j'en pense je trouve qu'il a
une dégringolade de la qualité du
programme
sarah télévision française depuis
plusieurs décennies qui moi me rendre
bien triste là dessus mais sur sur le
reste effectivement c'est très
problématique que le csa et ce rôle là
puisqu'il est neutre et clément
dépendants du pouvoir et que c'est une
autorité avant tout administratives et
qui dit administration dit effectivement
pouvoir hiérarchique c'est le principe
de base de l'administration
emmanuel macron a fait le déplacement en
israël cette semaine pour assister aux
commémorations du 75e anniversaire de la
libération du camp nazi d'auschwitz le
chef de l'état qui a réaffirmé sa
position sur l'antisémitisme et sa
volonté affichée de lutter contre toute
forme de haine
emmanuel macron qui a également comparé
la shoah avec la guerre d'algérie on va
en parler et nous continuerons avec la
même détermination et nous lutterons
comme je me suis déjà engagé contre
l'antisémitisme le racisme tout discours
de haine qui vient diviser notre société
et en ayez les fondements mêmes
l'antisionisme lorsqu'il est la négation
de l'existence d'israël comme état est
un antisémitisme un jean paul huchon il
ya un sondage également qui a été
publiée cette semaine qui dit que 34%
des français de confession juive se
sentent menacés au quotidien en raison
de leur appartenance religieuse qu'est
ce que ça dit finalement il ya une
propagation la haine qui est assez
inquiétante
ça ne m'étonne pas et ça date pas
d'aujourd'hui plusieurs années la
communauté juive est très inquiète parce
que bon il ya une multiplication
d'attentats ça peut arriver à tout
moment
il ya eu des départs aussi de gens de la
communauté qui sont curieusement il
serait parce qu'il ne supportait plus
ils ont vécu je crois avec beaucoup de
responsabilité de calme de sérénité dans
la communauté française aujourd'hui et
des familles entières qui sont
préoccupés notamment dans certaines
zones
jirel banlieue ou d'ailleurs où c'est
devenu difficile manon c'est même
impossible de se promener le soir avec
la qipao n'importe lequel signe de
reconnaissance
donc c'est vrai la communauté juive est
inquiète et je pense quand même que le
travail qui est fait par la police avait
pas tellement coupable ni contestable
le travail de prévention des attentats
et cetera devrait donner confiance mais
est ce que on a le même respect pour
l'histoire les traditions de la
communauté vivre qu'on avait à une autre
époque
je ne dirais pas ils ont l'impression
d'avoir dégringolé en termes d'affection
y compris dans le pays dans plus x a
encore assuré une résolution que j'ai
passées à l'assemblée nationale
justement pour qui associe finalement le
l'antisémitisme et l'antisionisme déco
l'état d'israël et nier c'est ce que
disait emmanuel macron encore une loi
pour pour légiférer contre onze les mois
je suis très sensible à ces questions là
d'abord ce que j'appelle moi mais une
proposition je suis sensible à ces
propos là parce que je suis fils de
déporté donc j'ai une sensibilité
particulière là dessus et je dois dire
raison légiférer non c'est pas qu'on a
raison de légiférer ou pas de légiférer
et c'est à dire que on est face à un
problème et je voudrais revenir sur ce
qui s'est passé en israël parce que
c'était assez intéressant
emmanuel macron fait un discours
formidable pour ceux qui l'ont écoutée
c'était un discours de haut niveau pour
yad vashem de vaud pour le 75e
anniversaire la libération de suite deux
grands discours qui n'étaient pas des
discours sur fait c'était celui de
poutine faut le dire est celui de des
manières et 1 conques avec de la chair
xve et qui avait vraiment quelque chose
quand on va pour la commémoration du 75e
anniversaire ont fait pas du en même
temps c'est à dire qu'on peut pas faire
du en même temps on va faire un incident
avec les services israéliens pour
montrer pour donner quelques signes en
disant que vous voyez moi je me laisse
pas faire parler
dire c'est pas l'objet c'était à
l'occasion des récents drames non c'est
toi le lendemain on fait pas le
lendemain une comparaison hasardeuse
entre la shoah la guerre d'algérie parce
que on a l'impression qu'on va
rééquilibrer les choses que au fond on a
donné quelque chose aux juifs
on va donner quelque chose à d'autres et
ça c'est nier nier l'importance du
discours qui fait il fait un discours je
vous le dis je les écoutais magnifique
tous les israéliens ont été
extraordinairement coucher il ya des
temps pour tout
rien n'est pareil à quoi ça sert de
comparer ces il n'y a pas de raison de
faire des comparaisons
chaque événement historique a sa
spécificité la guerre d'algérie est un
débat la shoah est spécifique
il faut pas mélanger les choses car si
vous mélangez les choses vous tombez
dans quelque chose de pire qu est cette
concurrence victimaire qui est une des
sources profondes extraordinairement
profond de l'antisémitisme notamment
dans les banlieues où on se dit mais
regardez tout ce qu'ils font pour les
juifs et nous et ça c'est mortel parce
que quand on touche à l'humanité ça
touche tous les humains et on ne fait
pas de distinguo
on va écouter justement cette phrase
d'emmanuel macron effectivement c'était
dans l'avion lors d'une interview
accordée à quelques médias français
écoutez je suis très lucide sur les
défis que j'ai devant moi
d'un point de vue mémorielle et qui sont
politiques la guerre d'algérie est sans
doute le plus dramatique
je le sais depuis ma campagne il est là
et je pense qu'il a à peu près le même
statut que la shoah pour jacques chirac
en 1995 même statut que la shoah jean
paul huchon aussi des choses comme ça
afin de venir
il ya une absence de culture historique
et même de connaissances tout court on
se laissera aller on s'embarque sur des
phrases qui n'ont pas de sens et très
franchement ça n'est pas admissible peut
pratiquement parler de génocide et à la
shoah il ya le rwanda il ya peut-être
deux ou trois autres questions comme ça
mais on ne peut pas casser la
spécificité pas raison
des traces de la guerre de turris et la
fin d'une guerre coloniale bon elle
s'est passé il ya eu il ya eu de très
mauvais comportements différents de
culture ah oui je pas vraiment que c'est
un manque de culture mais ça s'explique
vous êtes quelqu'un vous avez 40 ans et
vous pouvez parler notamment la sortie
des camps et tout ça mais mais non ça
n'existe pas il faut avoir un petit peu
de bouteille pour voir dire ces choses
là c'est pas c'est pas normal de prendre
la part de l'opinion la passe de
l'information ou permanence comme ça sur
lui alors qu'en réalité il n'y connaît
rien concurrence victimaire
ouais je pense yadlin peut-être de
l'inculture mais il ya quand même une
cohérence que je rappelle que pendant sa
campagne en 2007 il avait dit que lille
avait un crime contre l'humanité en
algérie j'ai ri à la colonisation et
sape avec un pas de plus
bien sûr il ne tient pas plus debout
près des anciens combattants oui c'est
le en même temps et là je suis assez
d'accord c'est le en même temps
permanent je pensais plus politicien qui
ça je pense qu'il sait pas ce que vous
avez vu juste pense que comme il ya eu
le discours sur la shoah il fallait en
donner un peu à côté et donc dire que la
colonisation voilà la guerre d'algérie
c'était pareil ski l'absurde idiot et
c'est très insultant pour la shoah je
viens ce même plus qu'insultant c'est
très problématique de la crise en salles
relate rivière peut-être aussi c'est
insultant pour l'histoire de france et
c'est insultant pour les anciens
combattants et c'est insultant pour
notre mémoire collective donc et je
pense que ça met de l'huile sur le feu
dans notre relation avec l'algérie on
absolument pas besoin de ça quand on
sait d'ailleurs le nombre d'algériens de
franco algérien qui existent qui sont en
france donc c'est à mon avis d'abord un
espèce de petits calculs politiciens
électorale de l'ue qui joue
effectivement sur la concurrence
victimaire bien sale pas au niveau et
qui ouvre beaucoup de boîtes de pandore
et qui va créer qui va créer à court
moyen et long terme beaucoup de problème
voilà donc je pense que c'est très
irresponsable ce que fait emmanuel
macron et il est régulièrement dans
cette dans ce genre d'irresponsabilité
et à force effectivement on entend
beaucoup ses discours un de la part du
gouvernement la haine contre contre les
juifs la haine contre les musulmans la
haine aussi contre les chrétiens
emmanuel macron
israël a pris fait et cause en tout cas
pour les chrétiens d'orient
ce qui est assez rare finalement on n'en
parle pas beaucoup c'est toutes les
religions qui sont qui sont ces vidéos
de deyne aujourd'hui on a vu deux
pèlerins quant à craquer à cause d'eux
parce que parce qu'ils sont catholiques
voilà parce que c'était dimanche et
qu'il y avait là la manifestation contre
la loi sur la sur la pma les chrétiens
d'orient vivent un drame un drame qui
n'émeut personne très peu de gens vous
avez quelques réactions de temps en
temps ses terres est un vrai drame qu'on
a vu en irak qu'on a vu en syrie qu'on
voit ailleurs qu'on est en train
malheureusement devoir au liban on verra
au liban avec la montée du hezbollah au
liban bref il ya un ensemble là dessus
je pense que ça doit être aussi un débat
majeur
simplement ce débat sur les chrétiens
d'orient et est un débat qui est biaisé
parce que on a l'impression que quand on
dit ça on est à droite voire à l'extrême
droite confort
c'est un débat vraiment qui est un débat
humaniste et jean paul huchon j'en suis
sûr le partage alors que c'est pas un
homme de droite
comme chacun le sait et que donc on peut
être là dessus et il faut faire
attention il ya une sensibilité là
dessus et que à ne pas vouloir nommer
les choses vous connaissez la formule en
les aggrave
on sait aujourd'hui qui a une détention
et on veut tout le temps préserver
préserver préserver non un moment donné
il faut dire les choses
aujourd'hui les chrétiens d'orient sont
vraiment des victimes l'antisémitisme
monte en france
l'islamophobie n'est pas l'un des points
majeurs il existe mais c'est pas un des
points majeurs aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui en france c'est le pays avec
la belgique et les états unis trois pays
dans le monde où des juifs sont morts
morts parce qu'ils étaient juifs
c'est quand même quelque chose lui
depuis la guerre depuis la guerre c'est
trois pays où se posent des tensions on
y prend un soin particulier
pareil pour les chrétiens d'orient
est-ce que la haine finalement ne vise
pas particulièrement les religions
florian philippot quelle qu'elle soit
aujourd'hui on peut citer aussi
d'ailleurs en france des incendies
d'églises qui se sont multipliées
récemment
c'est très bien c'est un phénomène très
récent et détale dimanche des tags etc
donc on voit qu'il ya quand même aussi
une volonté de viser la religion
chrétienne en france également
et ça c'est assez récent avec également
des profanations de cimetières qui sont
également très très nombreux nombreuses
est ce que les religions et la religion
normalement doivent avoir un message
d'amour bon est-ce que ça entre eux
c'est ce que ça crée de la haine c'est
un peu l'histoire de l'humanité aussi
c'est qu'il ya de la part de ces paquets
non mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui je
pense qu'en france particulièrement on a
un problème c'est que la religion a
beaucoup trop envahi ce débat politique
on a on à communautariser le pays on a
scindé le pays est socialisé
essentialiser oui et est en réalité on
met on mai par rapport avec quelques
années ou quelques décennies on met
beaucoup plus de considération
religieuse et puis les gens se sentent
beaucoup plus facilement attaquée dans
leur foi alors qu'il ne devrait pas
l'être parce que parce que la critique
doit être libre envoyer des
susceptibilités qui sont nés justement
née de cette concurrence victimaire et
on l'a vu tout ça est malsain voilà tout
ça est malsain et ça ne peut mener non
pas à des solutions intelligentes de
concorde nationale ça ne peut mener qu'à
une montée des tensions des
communautarismes et des haines
mais je crois que c'est très lié à ce
phénomène la religion la religion
remettons là à la place de la religion
qu une place plus ou moins importantes
selon les individus on n'a pas à en
juger
mais le débat politique et démocratique
ce n'est pas la même chose
jean paul huchon
la laïcité devrait permettre ça va me
permettre l'exercice égal de l'ensemble
des religions et c'est pourquoi nous
lisions avec l'expérience du politique
que vous êtes
oui bah ils s'étaient pas très
confortable d'être chrétien comme moi et
socialiste
c'est vrai avoue déjà à l'époque donc
cette usine s'était passé déjà quand
j'étais président de la région n'a aidé
aussi l'école privée parce que il y en a
il y en avait besoin dans certaines
banlieues ailleurs et ça n'a pas
toujours été bien pris mais je dois dire
que il ya une vieille vieille vieille
bataille contre les religions en france
et tout ça remonte on pourrait aller
élargir le propos ou dire s'il n'y a pas
de décentralisation véritable en france
c'est parce qu'on n'aime pas les
provinces parce qu'on a considéré que
les provinces étaient les anciens choix
et caetera et que la république allait
balayer tout ça c'est quand même une
question historique majeur barry et les
religions sont parfois utiles on cherche
donc il ya eu chaud je voulais demander
de plus
rappelez vous la nouvelle calédonie mais
bien sûr quand vous êtes un militant
vous avez raison alors il y avait toutes
religions et y avait les francs-maçons
il y avait tous et c'est là où on voit
aujourd'hui une dérive c'est à dire moi
j'ai adoré évidemment emmanuel macron
devant le mur des lamentations je
regrette qu'il ait pas souhaiter joyeux
noël aux chrétiens quand en france
il faut faire attention dans son
allocution il veut simplement cette
année
il faut faire attention à tout toute une
série de choses il faut faire attention
les religions sont en équilibre la loi
sur la laïcité a un avantage c'est que
si on n'a pas de blasphème en france
c'est parce qu'on doit considérer la
religion c'est ce que dit la
jurisprudence comme une idéologie c'est
comme ça que donc comme on peut
critiquer une idéologie on peut
critiquer une religion formidable ça
veut dire quand même qu'hier qu'il faut
aussi reconnaître l'apport que peut
avoir des religions évidemment islam
compris dans le débat public et que ce
qu'on peut regretter c'est que il n'y
participent pas suffisamment ou que de
manière essentialiser c'est à dire en
victime
ce qui est important aussi c'est
d'apporter une pierre à l'édifice de la
république
merci beaucoup c'est la fin de ce débat
merci olivier pardo on va passer au coup
de gueule à présent
[Musique]
et votre coup de coeur florian philippot
ce sont des batteries qui sont fabriqués
à partir de déchets nucléaires expliquez
vous alors c'est un coup de coeur qui
cache un coup de gueule alors le coup de
coeur affection c'est à bristol en
angleterre des chercheurs ont à partir
de déchets nucléaires créée un diamant
qui produit ne demandez pas comment ce
qui produit de l'électricité de
l'énergie de quasiment infinies pour au
moins 100 mille sept cent trente ans
jean vie éternelle voilà au brésil
éternel effectivement et donc ça c'est
quand même une espérance
ça mériterait à mon avis qu'on
investisse beaucoup là-dedans puisque
l'on sait qu'un des problèmes du
nucléaire ce sont des déchets et que
donc fui stands et des choix là et donc
il faudrait évidemment on ferait d'une
pierre deux coups investir énormément là
dedans plutôt que et c'est là que je me
glisse vers mon coup de gueule liés
plutôt que d'annoncer comme le
gouvernement l'a fait cette semaine
qu'on va fermer 15 réacteurs nucléaires
d'ici 2035 c'est à dire une quinzaine
d'années ce qui me semble est une folie
une folie totale
alors soit ça veut dire qu'on va revenir
à la bougie parce que notre électricité
sa 75% du nucléaire en france
soit on va faire comme la pologne et
l'allemagne
installé à auxerre oui ou achetés à
l'extérieur venant d'électricité
produite par le charbon ou nous mêmes
faire des centrales à charbon un bon et
c'est à dire qu'on va dégager un maximum
de gaz à effet de serre co2 et autres
joyeusetés dans l'atmosphère qui a pas
d'alternative de prévu se bat non non
non les éoliennes alors qu'on me parle
pas moi je suis 13 pour le renouvelable
n'a pas de problème enfin quoique les
éoliennes faut voir où on en met pas ce
qu'il faut pas non plus que tous les
paysages soient complètement dénaturé
mais de toute façon même si on mettait
des éoliennes partout en france sans
aucune exception on n'aurait pas du tout
du tout du tout à combler la l'énergie
produite par les réacteurs nucléaires
qui sont à des niveaux très très
supérieur et qui permette à la france
d'avoir l'électricité produite avec le
moins d'émissions de co2 par habitant en
fonction de son pib ce qui est quand
même une fierté que nous devrions date
valoriser davantage
je vais vous êtes d'accord jean paul
huchon va quand même passé à votre coup
de gueule à vous c'est oui un coup de
gueule contre le gouvernement qui selon
vous a encore fait preuve d'incompétence
t'expliquer une fouille par le conseil
d'état vient de le dire il dit qu'on ne
peut pas considérer que le projet des
retraites le projet sur les retraites et
suffisamment préparée et a été
suffisamment étudiée
pour qu'il y ait une sécurité juridique
dans le produit fini à écouter quand on
dit ça à près de deux ans des barres
d'acier avec l'arrogance bons rails et
une 2e 2e budget qui est apparu était
vraiment scandaleux c'est cette manière
mais non plus compter l'appellation
politique des petits maires alors d'un
seul coup d'un seul on va s'apercevoir
que 53 % de la population et déjà être
sans rien d'aberrant politique d'aidé il
de michel py tralala mille habitants
cela doit être fait pour éviter à la
république hommage de se planter
complètement mais c'est bien partis
quand même tous merci beaucoup à tous
les deux merci florian philippot merci
jean paul huchon pour être contribution
merci beaucoup olivier pardo je rappelle
que vous êtes avocat d'eric zemmour et
du cabinet opus merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions sur rt france c'est la fin
de deux pôles it mag
restez avec nous et merci à vous pour
votre fidélité
[Musique]
le dopage arme politique ou scandale
sportif oui c'est évidemment la scala
sportive puisque sa fausse toutes les
compétitions et c'est évidemment
contraire à l'idéal olympique
maintenant ça peut être utilisée est
manipulée à des fins politiques
c'est assez compliqué d'arriver à y voir
clair dans cette dans cette affaire
puisque d'un côté on a un ministre des
sports et l'ensemble de l'est